Jean-Luc Moury je suis en charge des
activités spéciales électroniques au
sein d'Airbus dans notre établissement
de d'Élancourt
[Musique]
les activités que l'on mène ici
concernent le développement de
l'ensemble des équipements électroniques
qui sont ensuite embarqués sur nos
différents engins spatiaux
on a à côté de ce marché là des marchés
qui sont plus orientés commerciaux dans
lequel on sait offrir des solutions
moins onéreuses à travers une baisse de
nos coûts on est en mesure aujourd'hui
de pouvoir accompagner un certain nombre
d'initiatives à travers les technologies
qu'on maîtrise à travers l'utilisation
de ces nouveaux composants de nouveaux
assemblages cela nous permet de pouvoir
offrir à nos clients des coûts qui leur
permettent eux de financer des missions
qui n'étaient pas finançables avant
[Musique]
on a besoin d'abord une organisation
projet donc avec des chefs de projet
avec des contrôleurs financiers des
contrôleurs planning on a ensuite besoin
d'ingénieurs pour designer ces
équipements donc pour les concevoir on a
ensuite besoin d'ingénieurs pour les
tester puisqu'il faut qu'on vérifie les
performances par rapport à ça et puis
bien évidemment on a besoin de les
fabriquer et pour cela on dispose de
l'ensemble des métiers de fabrication